today probably you're a bit anxious
maybe about some work you have to finish
people you have to see some chores
you've neglected anxiety often appears
to be about particular things promising
us that if only they can be overcome
we'll reach a stage of long-lasting
serenity and security but really if
we're frank about how we function the
problem really seems larger and more
fundamental beyond any specific thing we
happen to be worrying about looked at
over time with simply anxious to our
core in the very basic makeup of our
being though we may focus day to day on
this or that particular worry creating
static in our minds what we're really up
against is anxiety as a permanent
feature of life something irrevocable
existential dogged and responsible for
ruining a dominant share for brief time
on earth
tortured by anxiety we naturally fall
prey to some powerful fantasies about
what might finally bring us calm at
certain points especially in the north
the fantasies latch on to travel here at
last there would be peace under the
clear blue sky on the island eleven and
a half hours from here seven time zones
away with a warm water lapping at our
feet and with access to a seaside villa
Ronn pontoons it's just a matter of
holding on for a few more months and
parting with an extraordinary sum or
perhaps we'd be calm if the house could
be really as we want it with everything
in its place no more clutter pristine
walls ample cupboards stripped oak
limestone or perhaps we'll be calm when
one day we reach the right place in a
company
well the novelist sold of the film is
made while our shares are worth hundreds
of millions and we can walk into a room
full of strangers and they'll know at
once who we are or and this one we might
keep more private there might be calm if
we have the right sort of person in our
lives
someone who could properly understand us
creature with who make don't be so
difficult we'll be kind and playful and
sympathetic with a thoughtful compassion
of eyes and in whose arms we could lie
in peace almost like a child's blow not
quite travel homes status love the four
great contemporary ideals around which
fantasies of can collect yet despite the
promises and the passion expended in the
pursuit of these goals none of them work
there'll be anxiety at the beach in a
pristine home after the sale of the
company
and in the arms of anyone you could ever
seduce anxiety is a fundamental state
for well-founded reasons because we're
intensely vulnerable physical beings
with complicated network of fragile
organs all biding their time before
eventually letting us down
catastrophically because we've got
insufficient information upon which to
make most major life decisions we're
steering more or less blind because we
can imagine so much more than we have
and live in mediatized societies where
envy and restlessness is always a
constant because with the descendants of
the great warriors of the species the
others have you been trampled and torn
apart by wild animals
and because we still carry in our bones
into the calm of the suburbs the terrors
of the Savannah all of which isn't to
say that there are better or worse ways
to approach anxiety a single most
important move is to accept that will
always be anxious there's no need on top
of everything else to be anxious that
we're anxious the mood is no sign that
our lives have gone wrong merely that
we're alive so we should be more careful
when pursuing things we imagine will
spare us anxiety we can pursue them by
all means but for other reasons than
fantasies of calm and with perhaps a
little less vigor and a little more
skepticism
we should also spare ourselves the
burden of loneliness we're far from the
only ones with this problem everyone's
more anxious than they're inclined to
even the tycoon and the couple in love
are suffering we've collectively failed
to admit to ourselves what we truly like
we should learn to laugh about our
anxieties laughter being the exuberant
expression of relief when a hitherto
private agony is given a well-crafted
social formulation in a joke and lastly
we should hug not the forced intimacy of
most modern hugs
but the melancholy sympathetic way
Botticelli's Angels do it having come
down to earth to offer comfort to humans
for the brute facts of earthly existence
we must suffer alone but we can at least
hold out our arms to our similarly
tortured fractured and above all else
anxious neighbors as if to say in the
kindest way possible
I know
you